si on arrive comme le souhaite au
gouvernement un ouverture en octobre aux
boules virus au débarras il sera plus
question de douze ouvertures que tout le
monde se le dise elles comprennent donc
il faut qu'aujourd'hui on reste tous
mobilisés tous unis on en a que
du syndicat dans lequel vous êtes
c'est un combat qui est copain qui est
pas le combat d'un syndicat qui le
combat d'une profession voilà merci à
tous
aujourd'hui heures appelé après auprès
de moi une personne qui pendant le
confinement a été quasiment l'un des
premiers à s'insurger contre la
situation
il vous a enchanté par ses lives moi
j'ai une affection particulière avec lui
parce que bien sûr j'ai beau savelli je
voudrais qu'on appelle sébastien sortie
vous sentez et même s'il va dire
quelques conneries parce qu'il aime ça
ou la lumière des choses intéressantes
et je pense que on peut l'appeler lui
beaucoup plus fort que ça
c'est la technique je désire de te
passer le micro
merci même si on fait comment
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci d'être là
aujourd'hui
moi j'arrive de caster de rails donc
ensuite cassoulet qui dépote ce qu'on
vendait de la bande vidéo du sud on a
fait nos moteurs de route on était je
n'étais pas très chaud points pour venir
une manifestation fait un truc comme ça
mais là je suis soulagé je suis je suis
content d'être venu en plus ah oui très
ouais c'est humain mais dit non mais moi
je suis très saine nature dirait pas
comme ça mais voilà je merci merci merci
du fond du coeur et merci à tous parce
que depuis le début c'est vrai que la
première fois avec mathieu quand j'ai vu
ce qui se passait ça m'avait le côté de
ne pas entendre le mot discothèque salon
avait troublé et jusqu'aux jusqu'à
maintenant ben voila j'ai je suis encore
tomber parce que effectivement les
discothèques vous êtes le dernier match
de la vente dernier maillon de la chaîne
parce que je suis le dernier maillon de
la chaîne
la ram collectif métissé tous les
artistes tous annoncera le dernier
dernier puis quand vous allez quand vous
allez réouvrir j'espère que vous allez
roro dessous on sera juste derrière mais
on sera toujours solidaire avec vous et
merci d'être venus et merci à tous et en
tout cas quoi qu'il arrive la nuit
reverra le jour ça c'est sûr et c'est
pas un ver ans qui va nous en empêcher
[Applaudissements]
moi je voulais juste glissé sur le
groupe que j'ai créée avant moi devait
vous êtes plus de 7000 pour ceux qui
sont sur le banc alors ne vous inquiétez
pas contester quelque chose et que nous
voyez pas paraître c'est très simple
partir du boulanger la vidéo des miss
une fois je le remets pas cinquante fois
ça sert à rien la plus que le discours
de veron à l'assemblée ou comme ça n'ont
aucune inquiétude je n'ai rien contre
personne à part quand je lis des propos
insultants ou une faible raciste à
partir de là je dégage mais tout le
reste là je peux pas mettre un mur avec
50 fois cent fois la même chose vous
devez comprendre
non ne vous inquiétez pas et puis hop et
puis et puis j'arrive à dormir trois
quatre heures par jour
donc pendant ce temps je peux pas les
voir si vous avez des publications donc
quand vous inquiétez vous affolez pas
parce que parfois je lis des
commentaires qui place et on dit et à
soma riba
il nous a sanctionnés je sanctionne
personne moi ça c'est un vrai bon goût
qui est ouvert c'est pas un syndicat
c'est une chose où l'on échange à partir
rond ça déborde
je veux dire ça c'est vrai et attention
c'est répétitif je viens mais c'est tout
il n'y a aucune sanction dont vous
pouvez continuer à les déposer des
choses qui concernent la nuit qui font
avancer
d'abord la région vertueux parce que
d'abord ce qu'on veut c'est retravaillé
et après on se posera peut-être des
questions pour faire évoluer la nuit
pour faire évoluer le deejing mais on en
n'est pas là où nous condamner à vouloir
travailler travailler donc l'évolution
d'après il faut pas sauter les marches
il ya des marches pour les monter donc
on est en bas il faut d'abord vanté la
deuxième avant d'aller à la 5e donc
j'espère que vous le comprendrez toutes
et tous et ça m'évitera de de faire des
redites des messages en mp ou tout
simplement de lire quelques insanités
dont je vous passerais bien merci
[Applaudissements]
lancions d'écouter tous réunis c'est
qu'on a été bien sûr conviés b moi ce
qui me fait plaisir c'est que dans cette
assemblée bon il ya pas mal de gens que
je connais beaucoup plus qui me
connaissent ça c'est normal mais j'ai vu
quand même des gens des gens de tous
horizons et notamment j'ai vu des
tourneurs et je me suis dit tu vois les
tourneurs ils sont pas que là pour
prendre du pognon ils sont là aussi pour
soutenir ceux qui les font travailler le
reste de l'année et j'aimerais bien que
bourgeonnent quelqu'un qui est qui et
qui est un bon orateur ça je le sais
c'est philby secteur voilà si les idées
par là il était par là il est où voilà
on va déjà faire parler je voudrais que
tu puisses un petit mot pour la
profession ça lui fera plaisir clip ses
terres pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
visuellement et les lie et les roues les
magnifiques qui couvre tous les
dimanches
merci claude bonjour à tous moi je suis
dans le monde de l'année depuis presque
trente ans j'ai écrit mon appareil
j'écris mon agence il ya vingt ans en
travaillant avec vous tous je pense que
j'ai quasiment travailler avec tout le
monde
au fur et à mesure de ces années et
c'est vrai qu' on essaie d'être le plus
proche de vous puisque on fait partie de
votre vie si vous n'existez pas les
discothèques
nous les tourneurs on n'existe pas les
artistes n'existe pas non plus il ya
toujours des choses qui se font en
symbiose et moi la seule chose qui
défaut me gêne un petit peu dans notre
milieu du monde de la nuit
sicard moment ou à un autre on va devoir
reprendre cet égoïsme qui nous dessert
si tout le monde restait unie à chaque
fois claude a dit qu'on était 7000 sur
son groupe
malheureusement j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on soit 7000 aujourd'hui sur ces
places c'est dommage c'est dommage parce
qu'on aurait pu montrer encore plus de
choses comme quand on était tous unis et
qu'on était forts donc heureusement que
depuis toutes ces années on a je dirais
des piliers de la nuit
claude qui est là depuis
néandertal mais voilà on a la chance
d'avoir des vraies figures du monde de
la nuit dj faut c'est la même chose il
ya des patrons de boîtes mots que j'ai
connu il ya 20 ans ils sont toujours là
je pense à jean christophe des plages
des planches à deauville qui est là
patrick de la plage à bordeaux
évidemment j'en ai croisé plein et que
vous soyez une petite boîte au une
grosse boîte vous avez la même voie vous
avez la même force
on est tous unis pour la nuit et on est
tous unis la nuit voilà donc on espère
tous s'en sortir vite parce qu'on a tous
envie de faire la fête et on est prêt
mais il fait surtout pour moi le le mot
le plus important c'est resté groupé
rester solidaires commencez pas à faire
ce qui est arrivé à mathieu qui s'est
démené pour nous et qui relance et pris
une salve de choses désagréables
ça sert à rien à part une seule chose
démotivée un mec comme mathieu qui est
vraiment a dit dimanche soir tient si
lui s'en va
cloud s'en va moi je m'en vais on est
mort c'est pas le but donc gardez
toujours cet esprit positif et vive la
fête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là dit aujourd'hui c'est un
rassemblement apolitique il y avait tout
à l'heure thierry fontaine qui eux qui
représentent ligne h et je vais donner
la parole à d'autres syndicats qui sont
là et tout le monde a le droit de
s'exprimer au niveau syndical
donc je vais appeler oublier olivier du
snec menant de la plénière très fort
s'il vous plaît merci
le trec metallica professionnel on est
quasiment syndicales à double ailes unis
mais également un syndicat ou non dans
tous les établissements gay les
établissements gays également où
énormément souffert et également par
cette absence de futilité d'ouverture
parce que je voudrais aussi rappeler
c'est tout le monde de la nuit le monde
de la nuit correspond aussi à des
artistes autres à queen au vestiaire au
serveur et ça il faut pas les oublier
non plus c'est vrai que eux sont dans un
état aussi oui ils peuvent même pas
survivre
quelquefois par rapport à avilir une
discothèque et ça c'est très important
aussi de ne pas oublier les artistes
dans cette fermeture merci à vous et
restez tous unis merci merci je pense
maintenant le micro à part celle du g 10
jours à soutenir tous heureux de vous
retrouver enfin réunis et je me suis
inquiété tout début je me défendrai les
restaurants sur tous les instants mais
je me suis rendu compte que je me suis
dit mais que font les discothèques et
c'est là qu'on a sorti les oubliés de la
nuit est un des premiers à parler de
davis côté que sur les chaînes de
télévision nous avons été vraiment ce
qu'allait devenir les discothèques moi
qui ai fait pendant 25 ans la nuit à
paris dans des bars de la gare de l'est
que j'ai encore aujourd'hui je
m'inquiéter parce que les discothèques
je me suis amusé pour personne j'ai vu
la nuit je me suis vraiment inquiéter
vraiment très très inquiète et voilà je
vous remercie d'être tous présents mais
sachez que le génie et le syndicat
national des discothèques et des biens
de loisirs où se tiendront jusqu'au bout
de la nuit
merci à vous et à très bientôt j'espère
gagner discothèque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je continue le tour d'autres
représentants de witte qui nous aurait
tous devant de cannes tout bronzé les
magnifiques je suis pas je suis parisien
mais je suis venue exprès ce matin gt gt
sur une mission à 4 mais je suis rentré
ce matin
moi je suis patron d'établissement à
paris essentiellement barre et si je
suis ici aujourd'hui c'est pour unifier
notre domaine d'activité
c'est à dire que les boîtes de nuit ne
doivent pas se séparer des bars de nuit
et les bars de nuit doivent comprendre
le problème des boîtes de nuit
et si on est séparés on parle d'unité
mais il faut aussi que toute la nuit
sauver ni il faut aussi que les bars de
nuit ce qui effectivement font danser
sans avoir le type p comprennent qu'il
ya des gens qui souffrent et que on doit
être solidaire de ces gens là on ne peut
pas être l'un contre l'autre
on doit être ensemble dans cet univers
de ce bel univers parce que moi quand
j'ai commencé à sortir wendel dans un
bar de nuit
eh ben j'ai rêvé de rentrer qu'un
portier me laisse rentrer dans une boîte
de nuit j'étais émerveillé de voir un dj
en haut de son podium j'étais émerveillé
de voir des tas de personnes dansaient
et c'était mes premiers souvenirs de
nuit ici aujourd'hui ça fait 27 ans que
je tiens des établissements c'est parce
que d'abord j'ai poussé la porte d'une
discothèque
et c'est grâce à vous que move et d'en
donner envie de me faire ce métier
d'être là avec vous de vous soutenir et
je veux je veux le plus tôt possible que
la nuit soit égalité que les bars de
nuit et les discothèques travaillent
ensemble voilà bonne après midi
merci d'être venus quémander de toute la
france brown justement parlant de
quelqu'un qui fédère la nuit en parlant
quelqu'un qui est là depuis trente ans
pour vous de toute la france comme à
paris je voudrais que alexandre habibi
prennent la parole le patron du magazine
paraît nuit que vous connaissez tous
évidemment parce que l'organisateur des
trophées de la nuit le créateur de ne
pas renier avec vous indique menu et je
voudrais qu alexandre prennent la parole
parce qu'il a été aussi l'un des
premiers vous fédérer et à défendre
votre profession réunissant près de 127
députés au balajo pour que l'on défende
la nuit d'une manière un peu plus forte
merci d'être là
merci de me donner la parole je ne vais
pas la prendre longtemps simplement pour
vous dire que depuis 33 ans serait que
le groupe paris nuit parle de vos
établissements
on n'a jamais fait la différence entre
les bars les restaurants à ambiance
musicale et discothèques
aujourd'hui ce qu'est ce qui nous choque
c'est lydie quitter et la justice parce
que on peut pas dans le même temps dire
on ouvre les les clubs de sport où tout
le monde est confiné on ouvre les les
bars où les gens dansent moi je moi je
trouve normal que au fond bon c'est
comme ça et on peut pas dire non plus
qu'on ouvre les clubs libertins et qu'on
laisse fermer des établissements qui ont
fait tous